let's talk about generating comics with
JavaScript these slides are already
online I'm on you'll find me on Twitter
on s on and 0 my story really starts in
1984 when as a kid I asked my mom who's
the most famous person I was expecting
the name of some scientists that's who I
wanted to be an Albert Einstein was
certainly something that I was hoping
for but she said what Disney that was
odd now I knew Disney's comics I've
certainly seen their movies but I had
never heard of Walt Disney I didn't know
that there was a person called Disney
until that time then I started looking
at his work and pretty much reading
every single Disney comic and I watching
every single animation picture usually
standing at bookstores graphic novels
where and still are pretty expensive and
by 92 I'd pretty much made up my mind my
life's ambition is to draw comics for
Disney and I started very exit
aggressively and in two years I realized
one thing I can't draw anything zero
that was the end of that ambition but on
the other hand others can't draw so
there's nothing that stops me from using
these so I started hunting comics and in
99 discovered Calvin and Hobbes so you
may know this particular strip where for
instance Hobbes asks Calvin haven't you
put in your story yet he says no I'm
waiting for inspiration you can't just
turn on creativity like a faucet you
have to be in the right mood and Hobbes
asks what mood is that last minute panic
this is like one of my all-time favorite
the Calvin and Hobbes in fact last time
last minute panic is my motto
that's how I saw this light that got
rated as well last minute panic and I
use these comic strips and create
stories out of them use them as part of
presentations business presentations
technical presentations I mean heck them
giving JavaScript presentation on comics
here so the trouble though was that
these comics weren't really discoverable
so i
effectively spent seven years of my life
2001 to 2007 typing out every single
Calvin and Hobbes
so that I could search through it
there's a simple Excel interface that
I've built some of you may have has seen
it and what I would do is sit on a train
from Mumbai to Churchgate and using
simple macros as I scrolled through each
line on Excel it would change the strip
and I would look at it and say okay
everyone in the water
I refuse blah blah blah and as you can
see over time my typing speed also
increased if I type this much and I was
very proud created a website out of it
so if on this for instance I want to
search for that last minute
and I can strip that comes in pretty
quickly
or if I want to search for every
spaceman spiff for strip I just searched
for spaceman and go to the next one go
to the next one and I get all of these
and I was totally thrilled right so it
went on to the front page of Reddit
slash dot hacker news and I got a DMCA
takedown notice from you Comics that
just completely killed it so that was
the end of the next adventure uh over
the years has started grammar and we
assembled a design team and our design
team as the organization grew started
growing crazier than usual they started
putting together comics literally on a
walk this is one of the walls in our
office which is decorated with not even
sure whether I would call it comics but
it also has comics they started creating
comics for various situations so for
instance there was a client from the
Middle East who called us and said we
want to use big data ok cool how big is
your data they said see we want you to
forecast our revenue and we have the
last three years worth of revenue ok
what daily data hourly data a minute Li
data yearly data wait sorry you're going
to give me three three data points and
you want to predict the fourth said yes
but we can also give you GDP data what
our newly yes boss you need Excel that's
really what you need you can only need
paper and pen and we put that together
as a comic strip and told people look
for big data you don't really need much
beyond Excel if your definition of big
data something that fits in less than a
gigabyte of file size
that's Excel him quite comfortably
handle that and as we put these
characters together we had a discovery
we figured that it's possible to create
these in a way that others can use and
put together this open source
application library called comic Jeff
said grandma dot-com slash Commission
will show you how it works let's start
with one of the characters that we built
in the early days d you can choose the
angle that D is in the emotion that D
shows the pose that he has and different
combinations for each of these and maybe
flip them around as a mirror image
ultimately all of this gets translated
into code here so this is a piece of
HTML that if you insert in your code
then it generates this particular
character so now D has an angle straight
emotions angry frustrated if I change
the emotion to cry you just have to put
an emotion equals cry and that character
gets generated let's show you how this
works I'm gonna take the development
page here and open an example on code
pen so what you need is firstly you need
to have the library inserted for which
the code here is optionally include the
stylesheet definitely include comedian
and that's located at on NPM but you can
just use on package comm slash comma
Jeff when these libraries are included
and that is captured here in the library
section yeah so on package.com slash
comic gen is included here as a library
when you do that and you put in G class
is equal to comic John name is d and the
angle is straight emotion is smile pose
is thumbs-up that creates this character
with a thumbs up expression this was
literally also just copy pasting from
here so if instead I wanted to have this
character I would copy
this paste it in the HTML and that
refreshes eventually it's gonna get
there I hope yeah and you have this
character embeddable in any part of the
HTML the real discovery was twofold the
first is that simplicity actually wins
remarkably well Scott McCloud talks
about it in understanding comics where
he shows a really carefully crafted face
and says when you see that face you see
someone else and then he draws a smiley
says when you see a smiley you see
yourself it's possible to do effectively
the equivalent of emotion transfer which
is why emoticons work so well you send a
smiley the person on the other end sees
you smiling or they smile in themselves
so we found that emotions are pretty
powerful and started building a
reasonably large range of emotions the
second discovery was that composability
is pretty powerful too so we have
characters like for instance humans
which is an open source library where
you can pick from different heads
different bottoms and different bodies
and when you do that the number of
characters starts increasing
combinatorially so that's a pretty
powerful feature - and we started using
this in our stories so for instance we
took one of our 2014 stories who had
during the elections the parliamentary
elections the number of candidates with
the same name in different
constituency's was pretty odd for
instance there were 11 people called
Chandu Lanza who in maha sama exactly
the same name one of them was the
sitting MP and the remaining 10 were
obviously independents who were drawn in
to create some confusion there were two
Hema Malini's standing for election in
mathura one was the Hema Malini and the
other certainly was not they were and
one of the things that you notice about
the party is that it indicates which is
the party that was affected by this
strategy so if a man who belongs to BJP
finds that there is one more Hema Malini
in the same constituency people might
get confused and therefore we be jp's
vote is affected and it's interesting by
the way that there is but that Congress
was not affected by this strategy at all
I leave it there and let you draw the
implications and not into politics this
is about comics
and as we went along we started
realizing that now that it's
programmatic it can be controlled by
data as well so you can effectively have
these strips changing based on the
underlying data so which means that we
can start including this as part of
dashboards to express the emotion that
we want people to take away from these
dashboards to give you an example we
took this piece for the World Bank the
World Bank had a study that explained
how women face different challenges they
may they are for instance the laws are
different for men versus women in terms
of how they access institutions in terms
of how they can use property let's let's
take access that's accessing
institutions when it comes back here for
instance there are 19 countries in which
married women are required by law to
obey their husbands that includes
low-income countries like Mali and
Afghanistan as well as high-income
countries like UAE Saudi Arabia Qatar
and so on let's pick another random
there are 31 countries in which a woman
cannot legally choose to where to live
in the same way as a man and that
includes countries like Brunei Iran
Malaysia and so on similarly there are
31 countries where he cannot be the head
of a household it turns out that these
expression varies based on the severity
of the situation so there are only three
countries where you can't open the bank
account in the same way as a man but
there are 11 countries where you can't
apply for a national ID card in the same
way as a man not just here we started
introducing this into dashboards in
other tools as well so this is a power
bi dashboard where day is reasonably
happy that in the last quarter there was
an increase in sales in americas and in
APAC also there was an increase in sales
but it's pretty clear that in amia he
this performance is not so good and he
practically has tears in his eyes couple
of things happen when these go into
dashboards that executives see the first
level of interest when you see a comic
character it's effectively a promise
from the author that the content is
going to be a simple and engaging and it
usually lives up to the promise for a
couple of reasons the first is that the
creator is trying to do something
different the second when they start
introducing comics into these kinds of
dashboards there is a natural tendency
even on the part of the creator to
simplify their work to make it more
engaging so it's a virtuous cycle where
there is a promise and the promise is
almost self fulfilling and we've seen
this have a fair bit of traction in the
system so let's create a comic strip now
what we are going to do is take this
scenario D is at J s Phu and she's
skyping and says I'll call back later I
promise
and hopefully you catch the pun on that
question is there was a flicker so if
there are a lot of components on the
screen it flickers yes unfortunately the
artist who drew D drew D with a lot of
hair and with very intricate detail and
D in particular has pretty low
performance the subsequent characters
like Ringo and they have are men who
have less hair and over time you'll find
that the level of complexity starts
decreasing so but you're right when
using SVG on complex characters
especially with complex hair it becomes
a problem so there are two ways we are
looking at addressing this one PNG so
one of the options that there is instead
of using SVG use PNG and they are an
order of magnitude lighter so you'd find
that there would be less flicker when we
take a character like D and choose
different emotions so here you will find
that this and it's not pre cached or
anything now it's literally life the
other of course is caching load all of
these upfront and render them you know
the range of emotions it's not that
large so that's the second so ultimately
three strategies simplify the original
content itself second switch to PNG and
we recreated those and
third cache them I can't probably take
one more question before the switchover
yes if we go with the PNG we can't scale
it does get pixelated that is true and
therefore the choice is between SVG
which you would want to scale and PNG
which you wouldn't scale the thing
though is for the vast majority of the
users that we've seen comics put -
people don't really scale it it's just
an empirical observation at the moment I
don't know if that will hold ground we
are just discovering the users to which
comics are being put but so far for the
vast majority of the users that have
seen comics being put to they tend to
stay roughly at the same size so maybe
it won't matter we don't know if the
site is viewable in desktop and mobile
and the resolutions on both of them are
the same yes as you said it probably
should be fine let's create a comic
strip now and what we do is try and
replicate that very picture we are
coming up with a user interface where
it's possible to create the comic strip
from scratch directly on the UI today
this is not possible or what I'm showing
you is still in UAT but eventually when
that happens we can pick a character
such as D get rid of the holder and what
did we want her to look like okay she
from an angle perspective I think is
fine she should be reading looking down
and both should be holding a laptop and
we add a speech bubble which can be
smaller in which she says something
about callbacks and promises I promise
and that then gets moved to wherever it
needs to go
and with that we have the comic strip
created put it into your favorite editor
so you can export it as SVG put it into
illustrator or just take a screenshot
put it into PowerPoint so yeah this is
literally how I created this strip and
it takes a minute or two to create these
you can of course do this
programmatically also so in the
documentation on comic gen there are
some more sophisticated characters let's
take something near the bottom okay so
this is a full-fledged strip that is
programmatically created you can create
panels panels are these boxes and right
now the boxes are straight ideally you
want them to be hand-drawn like boxes
but that's coming with the caption text
so that just comes in as plain vanilla
text and then you put in the appropriate
comic gent characters and position them
you can move the comic gene characters
on the interface and will give you the
exact X&Y and that gives you this
particular strip which is just plain SVG
and with a certain amount of JavaScript
that's applied on to it the next phase
that we are exploring is how can we
start animating these characters based
on data in a more fluid form so LA Times
in 19 somewhere in the 1960s or 70s
carried an article in which a person
Chernov created a visualization showing
how different counties were reporting on
their surveys and he used a very
interesting principle he showed he
showed a fat face where people were
affluent and he showed a thin face where
people were not he showed a happy face
where people reported higher levels of I
think income something that correlated
with satisfaction
maybe job satisfaction and sad faces
where that was not true and used a
series of other factors now what that
allows us to do is control attributes of
the shape in a continuous fashion not
like an in a discreet fashion
the way you saw earlier and this can be
pretty powerful too so for example one
of the things that we put together for
this election was can we take the
candidates and use their profile to
create a drawing that characterizes them
so we can have those with a lot of
assets as having a round face and those
with very few assets as having a thin
face those that are young have lots of
hair those that are old have less hair
criminal cases the guy on the left is a
poor innocent chap whereas the person on
the right with red eyes clearly is far
from that and so on so this is what some
of the famous people look like Marion
remove the slightly innocent face Rahul
Gandhi not so innocent Arjun Singh looks
positively evil Gandhi definitely has
more head he's among the younger ones
smiling if they win so these people won
in much carnage in them they won in
their constituent constituency is
whereas Rahul Gandhi did not but it's
purely coincidence that I am you know
some of my slides have anti-congress
messages I hope that was not the
intended literally is a coincidence I am
politically unaffiliated but let's take
a bangalore central so this is the
result of these are the faces of the
bangalore central election that happened
recently the person who won is pc moore
who's smiling because he won and doesn't
have much by way of criminal cases and
moderately educated moderately old has a
reasonable number of liabilities to go
along with his assets whereas the person
who came number two there is one is
unhappy and is fairly rich and maybe
slightly younger as well and has similar
assets but slightly more educated
prakash raj has as much wealth slightly
older but little more in terms of the
crime status MK pasha is one of the
youngest that's true for election world
ad is all we can say quite innocent not
very affluent at a glance you get a
sense of the candidates profile and it
becomes a little easier to read it but
it's also something that's engaging and
this was a piece that we'd put together
for the media now while we are exploring
this another thing that we are also
looking at is can we animate these
characters dynamically so what does it
take
be able to take these sketches and draw
them there is this library but Weber
survivors are on order come on set
instant in which you can drag and drop a
shape so for example this is Priya who's
one of the new characters that's coming
up if I take Priya reading a paper and
drop this this is VG library allows me
to animate this real-time with a fair
bit of control you can decide what kind
of path timing function you want what
kind of duration you want and whether
you want them sequentially or you want
them one after another and so on so with
this kind of an approach if we are able
to simplify the characters to the point
where they're mostly line drawings that
allows us to create sketches that look
as if they are drawn by hand and are in
fact being drawn by hand so that's an
area that we are working actively on but
all of this is very much in development
and there are three things that you can
do right now to get working on comics
the first of course is to use them
there's a whole bunch of Japanese and
Chinese states that have started using
comic Jen and are putting them I have no
idea what they're saying I can't even
translate the images because I then have
to do OCR in Japanese and then figure it
out which was too much work but and
there are a number of people that are
tweeting on Twitter with a hashtag hash
Commission taking these and creating
strips so just using it to see what kind
of expressions and uses comics have in
in regular content that's an exploration
that a lot of people are doing and would
be of great help if you can learn and
teach the community the other kind of
work that people are doing the community
is creating characters we've had people
from Serbia Serbia Slovakia Japan
several people in India coming in and
saying we'd like to create a bunch of
new characters these are community
contributed characters and Donald Trump
is on the way as of yesterday we had one
person who came in and said I'm putting
together a Donald Trump sketch and this
is a portfolio that's growing as well
but as developers the other thing that
you can pitch on on to this library is
integrating with plugins so you saw the
I'll be a plugin there's a PowerPoint
plug-in that's coming in if you have a
framework library toolset whatever and
want to bring the plug-in the code is
out there you can certainly start
integrating it building a user interface
so that people can create comics in an
easier way is something that we are
working on if anyone's interested in
pitching and that would be pretty
powerful too and improving the main API
itself to make sure that it has more
functionality so how do we introduce
animation how do we introduce delays how
do we introduce composition layers all
of these are very open questions like I
said this is the early days for this but
this is a story of commission I must end
with my story as well we were working
with Star TV and started using
Commission in some of those dashboards
it was talking about how the viewership
was dipping across various regions and
starting here as many of you know was
owned by 20th Century Fox and early this
year was acquired by Disney which means
that I'm actually now drawing comics for
Disney comics are just one copy pasted I
encourage you to try and create as many
comic stories you can share them with
the world and enjoy comics are fun thank
you if time for questions
so you were affected by copyright laws
when you wanted to use Calvin and Hobbes
so do you see yourself for suing someone
else later when they're using your stuff
so the good part is Commission is
released under CC by that is your only
attribution license where the authors
want it or it's created in public domain
wherever possible what we are doing is
paying the authors and taking that work
and putting it under public domain which
means that not only we everybody
including the author loses the right to
sue anyone having said that what's
happening though is let's take Times of
India for instance they have a huge
portfolio of characters and they want to
use this so the question is can the
incarnation be used there so in those
cases what we can do is take the
technology give it to them and say apply
to your characters and use it internally
or put it outside with copyright would
create a site a portal wherever so that
the comics come up the my inspiration
actually came from when after the DMCA
takedown notice for Calvin and Hobbes
that I got I reached out to you comics
and said look I have the code I have it
all typed out let me give it to you let
me create a site for you whatever I just
want to search and the whole bunch of
people want to search no response so I'm
hoping to change that first if there's a
collection of comics let people use it
and how it happens I don't know so but
to your point yes there is always a
possibility but as far as possible we'll
try and get the comics out in the open
at least through technology and if
possible on the content side as well hey
I come from a company who's serving the
fortune 10 clients but the main problem
that we face is something innovative
something creative or something a little
comedian or including comics in one of
our - boats or anything that we create
right that might not get a good response
from the business users right and also
the business analysts are so-called
people who decide the decision boats are
- boats will not take it very positively
yes how do you think that we can change
this mindset
so that was exactly the same reaction
that I saw internally and externally the
good part is out of every dozen people
that say no this won't work maybe one
person maybe so the first thing to do is
to catch those people you ask them look
do you think it would work do you think
it'll work etc everybody will say no but
tell me one person who says it with a
little bit of hesitation catch them
second thing don't put it up late don't
apply it in a scenario which is
business-critical there are always PCs
and in a PUC there will always be
somebody who wants to try something
different now what we're finding for
instance is that collagen is proving
pretty powerful from a marketing
perspective it gets people hooked so you
go to the marketing team and say I'll
create something for you and tell people
that this is a whole new rage it
actually gives there's a lot of research
that's being done and mentioned that
Gartner has started talking about comic
generations they actually have you can
look at some of the storytelling work
that one of their analysts James
Richardson is doing and that starts
building some of the credibility around
the seriousness of comics also mention
some of the words like it drives
engagement
it drives adoption it reduces friction
have a portfolio of words which are
actually drawn from the research that
overcomes their objection and then then
it gets in into the marketing side of
things slowly there'll be a group of
people that start using it internally a
bunch of people started using it in
grammar Oh head of admin for instance
started sending all of his reports using
comet shell because it was easy and
people after he started sending it
people started reading those reports
otherwise it was like most admit were to
work here now he sent one yesterday
saying make sure that you book your
flight tickets at least one week in
advance because of that we can save a
solid 25% on the cost Wow every single
person read that so internal
communication then starts building the
culture internally that this is not
unusual this is part of the norm and
then slowly it starts trickling into
projects so that was our work as well we
started doing we started showing it to a
few clients and among the clients
there'll be one or two that are more
interested they'll say let's start with
that that's how it started and then when
one or two clients do it the sales team
looks at it and says oh okay that means
we can now take it to more clients
and this in itself becomes a product
offering or a differentiator very often
a differentiator so short answer hook
the early adopters getting them to touch
marketing drive POCs then showed in a
project then drive sales hello he had
goose bumps and he said I'm drawing
comics for Disney now it's such a great
moment so I just wanted to ask one thing
are you also considering you know making
some of these things responsive because
probably when you you know do something
like that you probably just take a head
shot of the character when they're
probably changing screens so since
you're already looking into animating
the characters is responsiveness also in
thing that you're probably considering
for these comics thank you for that
input have not thought about it I will
think about it I don't know the
scenarios where that becomes important
in the sense that right now I've been
treating comedian characters or even
parts as just images and therefore the
responsiveness of the images is the only
thing that I had factored and however
the given that now like you said we are
looking at animation and we are
potentially changing the shapes is there
a different shape that we should have a
different sizes that's an interesting
thought let me just think about it if
you absolutely out be it's an open
source repository just fork it create
whatever you want send a pull request or
don't whatever please yes that will be
fantastic ability X character let three
man sitting on a chair and I put in some
dialogue for that character so does it
automatically generate like a transcript
that okay man sitting in chair say so
and so well that's a fair question
especially coming after a talk on
accessibility I'll tell you a current
state of accessibility on this zero
absolutely nothing right now the
question is does a person who is fully
with site and fully capable in every way
going to even want to use this so right
now my question is is commission worth
it
so if it is then it's something let's
say I have some blog post and I
made this out there so I would ideally
want that any like everyone should be
able to like how we do for images right
yeah absolutely right and it is
important I'm not diminishing the
importance I'm saying it's ultra
critical right now what I don't know is
whether what we are exploring is
something that will even be used
I didn't mean definitely it's a fingers
crossed and the next hurdle to cross is
accessibility but you are the first
person to raise this question actually
out of the hundreds of people that I
haven't seen or heard and if right now
we don't even have a mechanism for
figuring out how to bring in that
accessibility because we don't even have
any studies on understanding how it is
being used once we figure that out I
think that's absolutely a positive next
step
oh I'm not saying that what I'm really
saying is that we are so far behind on
understanding its usage that
accessibility seems like a distant dream
at the moment and we'd love to explore
they use the usage on the ground thanks